is liking another girl's instagram photo
cheating no
just like do you think there's any way
it can cheat yes yeah no instagram is
literally like you're flicking you're
flicking and you just double tap
it's literally not real life
would there be any like red flags for
you probably all i don't like is if a
girl is a barbie and they're just
constantly on their phone constantly
worried about how many likes they're
getting how many followers are getting
how many four we're losing it's just
it's not real life my last long-term
relationship was four years i was
cheated on and i feel like i've
definitely got some like deep rich trust
issues now try not to let them affect me
too much but definitely going to need
honesty
hello
hi
nice to meet you nice to meet you i'm
karen i'm jimmy
it's quite early for a day i know what
the hell i'm nervous i wasn't nervous
i sat on his chair and i was like oh god
yeah
it is weird really nervous i don't know
why um so what do you do i'm a student
what do you study acting acting
i quite like that new um i do like
social media stuff influencing kind of
thing some people love it some people
hate it some people are a bit weird but
i think it's cool
why did your last relationship end oh my
god oh my god um that's a saucy one
i'm just going straight into this
everything is a learning curve okay
basically
if i'm just sum up white light
small eyes that right a compound effect
that build up and build up and build up
and then just yeah what you were lying
or she was lying um
yeah i started it started with me but
like they weren't deep just stupid
stupid lights
if i was like
out of shop
i would say like
oh i'm just
100 meters away do what i mean like just
stupid white lies like even if i was 10
minutes away i'd say i'm two minutes
away just why that why would you lie
obviously you thought that if i told the
white lie it would avoid a massive
argument do what i mean which is stupid
stupid i know i told you i'm struggling
to see how your relationship ended on
you saying you were two minutes yeah
i can't think of any
of the more serious ones
off the top of my head right now where
did your last relationship end um i
think it was like very rocky for a while
but we lived together so i think we like
kept just kept it going for like a while
when it should have ended i think
everybody ends up in the same situation
like it's like that and then it just
goes south really quickly
i'm sorry
what's your body kind
is it do you think it's important
yes i know like if it's 278
it's very specific
but you know what i'm saying what's the
like good number then that you'd be like
oh that's i don't know i don't know do
you think a girl's body count is
important
unless it's like a ridiculous number
like if it was like 50 would you be like
oh what do you think well that's more
than me it's what it means it's a
competition no like it's just like my
mom i don't mean it like that like
that's more than me it's like
like if it was like that cause
considerably more so than me
and it was something that it was going
to be like a serious relationship then
for some reason it would just like
play
right on my mind
um it's under 10. um
that's that's fine what about you under
10. okay so it is
[Music]
is liking another girl's instagram photo
cheating
no
just click like do you think there's any
way it can cheating yes yeah no
instagram is literally like you're
flicking you're flicking and you just
double tap and you flip for me anyway i
just flick double tap flick oh like do
what i mean it's not that deep at all
but then i feel like it can be deep
because it was like i thought i could go
from i've been like dating guys and like
they're like liking other girls pictures
who i like know and i'm talking like
he's not friends with like i'm totally
fine with somebody like liking their
mates pictures but like there's some
guys they're just
they're following like all girls they're
like constantly messaging girls they're
like liking why did you ask that
question
um i just feel like it's a good telltale
sign like i think people can have very
different views on it it just stresses
me out whenever a topic like that
instagram like in a picture is so deep
it's literally not real life
like it's just like
it's just like
something baffles me sometimes like
i just feel like it's a such a stupid
subject like it's just i just wish it
didn't even exist you know i mean yeah
it's like i wish
like i would have been alive in the
1950s to do it because do you think they
worried about liking pictures on
instagram no they don't know but there's
so much less stuff to worry about it
would just be
nicer
i also wouldn't have a job if that was
the case so wouldn't be ideal but
how much time do you spend on social
media it's not gonna be good
it's high it's a lot yeah yeah probably
like double what you can even imagine
like oh yeah i can understand for you
why you would spend a lot of time on
social media because it's your job and
you literally make an income from it but
like
if they're just on instagram purely for
the fun of it and like they're just
obsessed with instagram but they're not
going anywhere with it does that make
sense
i don't know it's just like you don't
want to have fun on instagram no no i'm
joking i think because i have to be on
it for my job i like being off it you
know what i mean so i don't think like
it's never been
a problem but i do sometimes feel like
people don't take the job very seriously
what is a job like if it is a job no but
it is a job like i don't understand i
don't think that so like i noticed a lot
of people just use instagram for like
posting their saturday night outing so
do you use like social media a lot that
really i do i'm trying to at the minute
post more and stuff to try and
get myself out there i do want to do
youtube channels like
that that is a goal of mine like i just
want to do it
what is the worst thing you've done in a
relationship
the worst thing i have done in a
relationship
i haven't cheated that's the start okay
so um
nothing i don't think i've done anything
with that that's good you don't have to
turn things against me no like it's
always just been something small it's
built up and built up and built up and
built up and like maybe me just not like
listening to the what the person was
saying and just like disregarding it do
what i mean and just maybe doing it
again without thinking i'm doing it
again before you think do what i mean
again
yeah no okay that's quite good but
you've never seen that no that's scary
i feel like i probably have some like
trust issues
from being cheered on the phone i feel
like it's just good to know like i do
really think people can change i'm not
like one of those people who's like i'm
telling you no people can say like you
know some people like want to cheat
always achieve stuff like that i don't
necessarily think that's true but i also
think it's interesting what happened
so like we were like very much i thought
we were very much okay like the
relationship was like fairly strong i
would say and just like one random night
out and do something yeah
so that wasn't great for me but
what's the um thing that you've done in
a relationship
have you cheated
no
i feel like i've probably done some like
questionable stuff you know when you're
in like the weird like talking stages or
like the breaking ups or like nobody's
perfect a lot of on and off situations
[Applause]
do you guys want to go on another date
for me whenever i'm dating someone i
feel an instant like
yeah
i don't feel like doing i mean but
you're
like
you're very pretty and you're lovely and
you're interested but for me i just
don't feel that like instant you know
connection
i thought i would get along with you
really well like it was a good date but
just
what an idea like i just thought you
know what i mean yeah
it was a nice chat it was a nice chat
did i fancy her
no within like literally 10 seconds you
just knew that that wasn't there do what
i mean nothing to do with a girl she was
lovely just
the spidey senses were not tingling you
know what i mean like
i didn't think there was actually that
much chemistry i also feel like i don't
know how much you would say about like
lies on camera so i'm thinking if he's
saying to me on like a first date white
lies would it be something like a lot
more than that obviously trust issues
for me is like number one like i need
somebody honest who i can trust so i
feel like that would be a bit of a red
flag for me
[Music]
what is your body count
i actually knew this was coming as well
you know all my days act cool so the the
honest answer is i don't know in it
what'd you say it's over 50.